[Music]
this is CL and Ocelot she is beautiful
but her beauty is her downfall
twice the size of an average house cat
for which shorter than average legs
speed isn't their specialty they ambush
rodents birds fish if it's meat now
later
we almost lost the Ocelot their alluring
coat with its distinctive pattern was
highly divided in a third tree they were
hunted aggressively it used to be that
you could find them throughout the
southwestern US and all the way down to
the bottom of Brazil now there's only 40
left in the wild in Texas more exist in
pockets of Central and South America but
the danger of shrinking habitat is
always looming this is the Ocelot
[Music]
every year relieves about 20-30 species
that are gone forever
and using this technology I think that
we can preserve and save those beaches
that have been lost scientists at the
University of Georgia are attempting to
use DNA from endangered cats to save
them from extinction
what we're trying to do here and collect
skin cells from endangered species and
actually turn them into sperm are a the
goal is to develop a tiger embryo and
artificially inseminate a house cat
which will then give birth to a baby
tiger because of the extensive knowledge
of domestic cats reproductive systems
the risk of failure is significantly
lower than if using a tiger as a
surrogate we know that we're going to
have a lot of hurdles and so what we
want to do is start off with an animal
we know very well so we thought cats was
a good starting point the three-part
process of creating an artificial embryo
begins with collecting skin cell samples
from endangered species we got these
samples from Zoo Atlanta they collected
the boxes from their Sumatran tiger and
their clouded leopard
those skin cells are then turned into
stem cells which will later be
reprogrammed into sperm and eggs
allowing for the creation of an embryo
once we have these sperm and eggs we'll
combine them together we'll get a
developing embryo and then the ideas
were going to transfer them into a
domestic cat and hopefully in a few
months we'll have a number of kittens
from that individual one of the greatest
challenges of the team has faced has
been developing the technique to
transform skin cells into stem cells a
necessary task that they have yet to
accomplish we are still waiting to make
that leap from skin cell to stem cell
and I think we're finally on the
doorstep for a ready to go
[Music]
by collecting and freezing skin cells
samples from various animals scientists
are effectively providing a road to
bring back species that may become
extinct in the future in a single tank
you could have a bio bank of two three
hundred different species and enough
individuals in each box where you can
use this technology to repopulate lost
species
I'll never give up essentially new laws
I can keep building great science and
exciting things I just really think
danger species are important to conserve
and they're worth the effort
[Music]
the trick is trying to think like a cat
it's one thing to think boded be like if
I were a cat that's another thing to try
to figure out well what is it like for a
cat to be a cat so a different ways of
creating per kind of sub David Thai
classical musician mostly by trade play
the cello
in the national company M that came up
with the idea of writing music for a cat
you're my bird songs for study
let's slow them down captain not
variable though I'm not particularly
social the ultimate goal is to be able
to communicate in something like their
language
what other sounds are there that you
know cat would enjoy most of the brain
development of cat happens outside the
womb I thought the sound of suckling
there's a reward related sound that all
cats will have heard as the brains were
forming the swishing kind of shot yeah I
would totally use that I'd name that
after your jacket that's my li w swish
another example of sound occurring
when you play this music how does a cat
react exactly there are things like they
would rub up against the speaker's it
shows kind of ownership and but showing
just attention and it tends to be more
comforting to those cats who have had
something of a hard life because that
cats a need more comfort are more
comforted by it do you have a cat no no
I actually don't climb allergic to cats
you're allergic to cat yeah this is ayah
and sagu too adorable clouded leopard
cubs don't be fooled by the youthful
spirit clouded leopards are some of the
most shy mysterious and elusive cats
besides their shy nature they have a
steadily declining population making it
even harder to spot them in the wild
as far as big cats go clouded leopards
are the smallest these two little girls
will top out at around 3 feet when fully
grown native throughout Asia they live
in diverse habitats from the rain
forests of Indonesia to the foothills of
the Himalayas they pack a powerful bite
- as they have the largest canine teeth
relative to body size of any wild cat
they have short powerful legs and ankles
that convert eight backwards making them
elite climate
beyond a quickly shrinking habitat
poaching remains a huge problem as their
skin claws teeth bones and meat are all
sold on the black market this is the
clouded leopard
[Music]
this is kurta
a three year old African cheetah
critically endangered less than 8,000
remain in the wild the African cheetah
is built for speed it's the world's
fastest land animal
clocking 0 to 60 miles per hour in a
mere 3.4 seconds long and lean with a
flexible spine they use their tail as a
rudder steering when running after prey
they stalk their prey
under the bright Sun at the African
savannah the tear marks that run across
their face help reflect the glare of the
Sun much like football players apply
paint beneath their eyes before a game
they once roamed across all of Africa
but today are found in less than a
quarter of their historic range habitat
loss poaching and loss of prey are all
threats to this beautiful cat this is
the African cheetah
this is Sharda and this is Lina two
young serval these slender medium-sized
cats are native to sub-saharan Africa
and have a gorgeous golden coat with
black spots serval have the longest legs
of any cat relative to body size their
ears are also impressively large and
convert eight 180 degrees giving them a
keen sense of hearing which helps them
locate prey efficiently their long lean
and can jump up to nine feet in the air
to catch unsuspecting birds flying by
beyond Berg they mostly feed on rodents
insects and reptiles servos prefer
wetlands and areas the tall grasses near
water
unfortunately degradation of these
wetlands is leaving them with less and
less space while hunting for their
prized Kirk remains a big concern this
is the serval
[Music]
likely has the most difficult job in
Cincinnati Zoo he has to play with
babies all the time he's never shown any
aggression or snap if he gets upset kind
of like any mom would usually say my
name is dawn Strasser and we're at the
Cincinnati Zoo and Botanical Garden
likely is a five-year-old Australian
Shepherd we got him from a rescue and I
use him in the nursery as a nanny or a
companion dog you can sit back you and
you're taking a nap
blakeley's here for the main purpose of
teaching the babies the correct animal
cues as they grow up so when they are
introduced back to their own kind they
know what a purpose behavior is he
teaches them how to play how to interact
I can tell them no don't bite me but I'm
not an animal and I don't give the same
cues that he can so we make a great team
[Music]
my appointed cameras yes my open camera
Blakely has worked with cheetahs ocelots
a-talkin betters foxes a warthog
Wallabies to name a few he's working on
sports baby cheetahs right now it's been
a long seven weeks for him with these
little cheetah cubs and he I think tired
as he's on alert to 24 hours a day if
they start making too much noise he'll
come and get us like something's not
right something's not right
he's kind of like a second set of eyes
for us too a lot of times they still
recognize each other like Dale to talk
in he breeds when they see each other
he'll they'll still run up at front and
grunt adding and he'll come jump up on
the wall and kinda like hey how you
doing
thank you yeah well I'd like to think I
have an office phone pretty sure too
[Music]